हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू ऑल। सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे
रही है?
सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है? प्लीज
टेल मी इन चैट। यस या नो।
सुनाई दे रही है तो अच्छी बात है। फिर आप
लोगों को अगर मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है
तो बहुत अच्छी बात है।
कैसे हो आप लोग?
कैसे हो? सब लोग अच्छे हो?
तो एक चीज और मुझे बता दीजिए सबको
कि प्रीवियस क्लास से रिलेटेड डाउट क्लियर
है?
और उससे भी पहले एक चीज बताइए कि कौन आज
क्लास में फर्स्ट टाइम आया है। मतलब डीएई
की सीरीज जो फर्स्ट टाइम देख रहा है। ऐसा
कोई है क्लास में जो फर्स्ट टाइम डीएई की
सीरीज को देख रहा है।
फर्स्ट टाइम जो डीएई की सीरीज को देख रहा
है। ऐसा कोई है?
कोई है ऐसा
कोई नहीं है
ओके यू आर द फर्स्ट टाइम प्रोफेशनल यूज
3 ओके यू आर द न्यू वन एंज प्रियांंशु यू
आर द न्यू वन
अब्दुल नहीं यह बग बंटी का कोर्स नहीं है।
देखिए सबसे पहले मैं बता देता हूं डीएचई
की क्लास चल रही है। डीएई क्या है?
डेफोनिक्स एथिकल हैकर एसेंशियल यह एक
एथिकल हैकिंग का इंडस्ट्रियल लेवल कोर्स
है। इंडस्ट्रियल लेवल मतलब कि जैसे
इंडस्ट्री में पेन टेस्टिंग की जाती है
उसी टाइप का यह पेन टेस्टिंग कोर्स है। और
इस कोर्स का बेनिफिट आपको क्या मिलेगा कि
यह कोर्स आप जब कंप्लीट कर लोगे आप सीएच
क्लियर कर सकते हो। ईजीपीटी जैसे एग्जाम
क्लियर कर सकते हो और भी कुछ और जैसे कि
अगर आप ओएससीपी जैसे एग्जाम की भी तैयारी
कर रहे हो तो वो तैयारी करने से पहले आपके
जितने भी फंडामेंटल्स है आपके जो भी
अप्रोच रहेगी वो सारी की सारी चीजें इसके
ऊपर रहेंगी। क्योंकि अगर आपने इस सीरीज को
कंप्लीटली डेडिकेटली कंप्लीट कर लिया
बिल्कुल डे वन से लेकर क्लास वन से लेकर
और जितनी भी क्लासेस होंगी उसको फिनिश कर
लिया ध्यान से सुन लिया समझ लिया
प्रैक्टिस कर लिया तो इस चीज की 100%
श्योरिटी है कि आप क्या है कि जब एडवांस
लेवल पर काम करोगे जब एडवांस पेन टेस्टिंग
सीखोगे तो आपके जो फंडामेंटल्स है आपका जो
बेस है वह बिल्कुल क्रिस्टल एंड क्लियर
होगा। ओके
तो चलिए फिर हम सेशन को स्टार्ट करते हैं।
तो स्टूडेंट मुझे पता है इतने ही आते हैं।
तो फिर भी आज अच्छी स्ट्रेंथ है। कोई
दिक्कत नहीं। तो चलिए फिर सेशन स्टार्ट
करते हैं हम। तो अभी हम धीरे-धीरे क्या है
प्रैक्टिकल सेशन में एंटर करना स्टार्ट
करेंगे फॉर योर काइंड इनेशन। क्योंकि आज
का जो टॉपिक है वो है आपका वीबीए मै
फंडामेंटल्स के बारे में पार्ट टू। तो मैं
आपको बता देता हूं कि प्रीवियस क्लास में
हमने क्या पढ़ा था। प्रीवियस क्लास में
हमने क्या पढ़ा था?
प्रीवियस क्लास में हमने पढ़ा था कि वीबीए
क्या होता है? वीबीए क्या होता है? वीबीए
मतलब विजुअल बेसिक्स फॉर एप्लीकेशन। तो
मैंने आपको बताया था कि जो वीबीए है वो एक
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज है जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
के द्वारा डेवलप की गई थी। ओके? जिसका
प्राइमरी गोल है जो Microsoft Office शूट
है जिस जैसे कि आपका Microsoft एक्सेल है
Microsoft Word है Microsoft Powpoin है
एक्सेस है या आउटलुक है उसके अंदर अगर
आपको ऑटोमेटिक टास्क परफॉर्म करने हैं या
आपको अपना ऑटोमेशन परफॉर्म करना है या
उनकी फंक्शनैलिटी को एक्सटेंड करना है तो
आप किसका यूज़ कर सकते हो? वीबीए का यूज़ कर
सकते हो। वीबीए प्रोग्रामिंग का यूज़ कर
सकते हो। जैसा कि मैंने आपको बताया था
प्रीवियस क्लास में कि वीवीएस
स्क्रिप्टिंग के जरिए आप चार चीजें कर
सकते हो। ठीक है? बेसिकली चार चीजें कर
सकते हो। मेनली आप रिपीिटेटिव मैनुअल
टास्क को ऑटोमेट कर सकते हो। जैसा कि
मैंने उसको काफी डिटेल में एक्सप्लेन किया
था कि रिपीटेटिव मैनुअल टास्क क्या होते
हैं? कैसे उसको ऑटोमेट किया जा सकता है।
दूसरा मैंने आपको बताया था Windows एपीआई
के साथ इंटैक्ट कर सकते हो। यह भी मैंने
आपको बताया था कि Windows एपीआई होता क्या
है और यह इसमें कैसे आप उसके साथ इंटैक्ट
कर सकते हो। तीसरी चीज मैंने आपको बताई थी
कि कस्टम यूजर डिफाइंड फंक्शनंस आप क्रिएट
कर सकते हो जो खुद के यूजर डिफाइंड
फंक्शनंस भी क्रिएट कर सकते हो विद दी
हेल्प ऑफ अ वीबीए और फोर्थ वन मैंने आपको
क्या बताया था कि जो होस्ट एप्लीकेशन है
जो आपका एक्सेल है आपका पावर पॉइंट है
आपका वर्ड है उसकी जो यूआई है आप उसको
मैनपुलेट और कस्टमाइज भी कर सकते हो एज पर
योर रिक्वायरमेंट। ये जो चार पॉइंट थे इन
चारों पॉइंट को मैंने काफी डिटेल में काफी
बारीकी से एग्जांपल के साथ आपके सामने
प्रेजेंट किया था। आपके सामने समझाया था
और उसके बाद मैंने आपको फीचर्स भी समझाए
थे वीबीए के। तो आज का जो हमारा टॉपिक
रहेगा वो टॉपिक है हमारा वीबीए मैक्रोज़।
वीबीए के बारे में हमें पता चल गया अभी
मैक्रोज़। क्योंकि हमें क्या करना है? हमें
अपना पेलोड बनाना है। हमें अपने ड्रॉपर्स
बनाने हैं। तो ड्रॉपर्स और पेलोड बनाने के
लिए सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के लिए हम क्या यूज़
करते हैं? सबसे ज्यादा कॉमन चीज क्या होती
है? वीबीए का यूज़ करते हैं। मैक्रोज़ का
यूज़ करते हैं। अगर किसी भी Microsoft
Word, किसी भी पीडीएफ में या किसी
Microsoft Word में या किसी पीपीटीज में
या किसी एक्सेल फाइल के अंदर हमें अपना
कोई पेलोड हाइड करना है तो वो हम कैसे कर
सकते हैं? कैसे डिज़ाइन कर सकते हैं? या उस
चीज की ट्रेनिंग चल रही है। तो मुझे एक
बार बता दीजिए कि जो फंडामेंटल मैंने
प्रीवियस क्लास में आपको बताया था क्या वो
सबको क्लियर है? सबको समझ में आ गया था।
देखिए प्रोफेशनल यूज़ अगर आप नितेश नितेश
सर से पढ़ना चाहते हो तो उनसे पढ़ लीजिए
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है क्योंकि नितेश सर बग
बाउंट पढ़ा रहे थे। मैं अभी पेन टेस्टिंग
पढ़ा रहा हूं या एथिकल हैकिंग सीरीज बोल
सकते हैं वह पढ़ा रहा हूं और इसमें वेब
एप्लीकेशन का पार्ट भी कवर होगा जल्दी आने
वाली क्लासेस में अगर आपको रिवीजन करना है
या आपको सीखना है तो ओके बाकी
चाहे नितेश सर पढ़ाएं चाहे आपको कोई भी
ट्रेनर पढ़ाए डेफोनस एकडमी के ऊपर आपके
साथ क्वालिटी के साथ कॉम्प्रोमाइज नहीं
किया जाता कंटेंट और क्वालिटी हमेशा ए1
रहती है हमारी तो सबसे पहले हम बात करते
हैं बीबीए मैक्रोस के बारे में वीबीए
मैक्रोज़ के बारे में पढ़ने वाले हैं। ओके?
तो स्टार्ट करते हैं वीबीए मैक्रोज़। इन द
कॉन्टेक्स्ट ऑफ क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स इन द
कॉन्टेक्स्ट। मैं एक बार पेन निकाल लेता
हूं। दिस इज़ माय पेन। इन द कॉन्टेक्स्ट ऑफ
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स एंड वीबीए। विजुअल
बेसिक्स फॉर एप्लीकेशन। मैक्रोज
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
रेफर्ड टू स्मॉल प्रोग्राम्स और स्क्रिप्ट
रिटन इन वीबीए दैट ऑटोमेट टास्क एंड
एक्सटेंड द फंक्शनलिटी ऑफ एप्लीकेशन
पर्टिकुलरली विद इन द माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस
शुड। इस लाइन का क्या मतलब है? अगर हम
क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स और वीबीए की
कॉन्टेक्स्ट में बात करें तो मैक्रोज़ क्या
है? मैक्रोज़ एक स्मॉल प्रोग्राम है या एक
छोटी सी स्क्रिप्ट है जो वीबीए
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज में लिखी जाती है
आपके टास्क को ऑटोमेट करने के लिए या जो
आपकी एप्लीकेशनेशंस है उसकी फंक्शनैलिटी
को एक्सटेंड करने के लिए जो एक स्क्रिप्ट
या स्मॉल प्रोग्राम लिखा जाता है उसको हम
बोलते हैं मैक्रोज़ और कौन सी लैंग्वेज में
विजुअल बेसिक बेसिक्स फॉर एप्लीकेशन वीबीए
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज में जो लिखा जाता
है होता है छोटा सा प्रोग्राम या
स्क्रिप्ट वह कहलाता है आपका मैक्रोज़
सिंपली पुट ए मैक्रोज़ इज ए पीस ऑफ वीबीए
कोड एंबेडेड इन ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट्स। अगर
सिंपल शब्दों में बात करें मैक एक पीस ऑफ
कोड होता है जो वीबीए प्रोग्रामिंग
लैंग्वेज में लिखा जाता है और जो किसी
ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर एंबेडेड किया
जाता है या हाइड किया जाता है या किसी
ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट के अंदर छुपाया जाता है।
मतलब एक पीस ऑफ कोड एक छोटा सा प्रोग्राम
जो वीबीए प्रोग्रामिंग की लैंग्वेज वीबीए
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज में लिखा जाता है
और जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस डॉक्यूमेंट्स है
चाहे एक्सेल है आपका पीडीएफ है आपका जो
वर्ड है या पीपीटीज है उसके अंदर क्या
किया जाता है उसको एंबेड किया जाता है
हाइड किया जाता है छुपाया जाता है ताकि वह
ऑटोमेटिकली जिस पर्पज के लिए इसको बनाया
गया है वह अपना पर्पज फुलफिल करे जिस
पर्पज के लिए इसको को बनाया गया है वो
अपना पर्पस फुलफिल करे। नेक्स्ट मैक्रोच
हैव बीन पॉपुलरली वेपनाइज्ड टू फैसिलिट
फैसिलिटेट द एग्जीक्यूशन ऑफ आर्बिटरी कोड
और एग्जीक्यूटेबल।
मतलब क्या है कि ऑटोमेशन के अलावा साइबर
सिक्योरिटी और क्लाइंट साइड अटैक एनालिसिस
के कॉन्टेक्स्ट में जो मैक्रोस है उसका
जिक्र बार-बार आता है। आई एम रिपीटिंग
अगेन। ऑटोमेशन के अलावा जो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी है और जो क्लाइंट साइड अटैक्स
है उसके एनालिसिस के कॉन्टेक्स्ट में जो
मैक्रोस है उसका जिक्र बार-बार आ जाता है।
ऐसा क्यों? क्योंकि हिस्टोरिकली अगर बात
करें तो जितने भी थ्रेट एक्टर्स थे
उन्होंने क्या किया? जितने भी जो कस्टम
कोड थे जो एक्सटर्नल बाइनरीज थी उनको
एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए मैक्रोज का काफी
यूज़ किया है। अगर हम इतिहास में बात करें
या हिस्टोरिकली बात करें तो इससे पहले
वीबीए बेस जो वायरसेस थे वीबीए बेस जो हम
बात करें मालवेयर थे पेलोड थे वो ज्यादा
यूज किए जाते थे किसी भी कस्टम बाइनरी या
एक्सटर्नल बाइनरी को एग्जीक्यूट करने के
लिए कोई फाइल को ड्रॉप करने के लिए
डाउनलोड करने के लिए या अपना कोई मिलीसियस
टास्क परफॉर्म करवाने के लिए या रिवर्स
सेल गेन करने के लिए यह सारी चीजें की
जाती थी लेकिन ऐसा क्यों हुआ? लेकिन ऐसा
क्यों हुआ?
क्यों वीबीए का यूज किया जाता था? तो इसको
समझने के लिए आपको पीछे की जो Microsoft
Office की सिक्योरिटी हिस्ट्री है, उसको
समझना होगा। जो पीछे बैक बैक में जो
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट की जो हिस्ट्री है, जो
सिक्योरिटी की हिस्ट्री है, यह चीज़ समझने
के लिए कि वीबीए क्यों यूज़ की जाती थी?
उसकी हिस्ट्री को समझना पड़ेगा। तो चलिए
फिर उसकी हिस्ट्री को समझते हैं। नाउ
हिस्ट्री और एंड इवोल्यूशन ऑफ माइक्रो
सिक्योरिटी। तो लेट्स सी कि समय के
साथ-साथ जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस था उसने भी
अपने जो माइक्रो सिक्योरिटी है उसको कैसे
इवॉल्व किया? कैसे बढ़ाया। मतलब जैसे-जैसे
समय बदलता गया वैसे-वैसे जो माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
थे उसने जो उसके अंदर जो वीबीए मैक्रोस
यूज़ किए थे उसकी सिक्योरिटी को भी
बढ़ाया। तो सबसे पहले हम बात करते हैं इरा
वन लेट 1990
दिस माइक्रोसॉफ्ट फीचर्स गॉट अब्यूज्ड बाय
कंप्यूटर वायरस इन द लेट 1990 मेनली ड्यू
टू इट्स पावरफुल फंक्शनलिटी एंड द फैक्ट
दैट एट दैट टाइम एंड द फैक्ट दैट एट दैट
टाइम ऑफिस फाइल मैक्रो्स वर ऑटोमेटिकली
एग्जीक्यूटेड बाय डिफॉल्ट
मतलब 1990 के समय
जब जब भी किसी डॉक्यूमेंट में मैक एंबेडेड
होता था मतलब 1990 में या 1990 के समय में
जब भी किसी डॉक्यूमेंट में मैक एंबेडेड
होता था तो फाइल ओपन करते ही जो मैक था वह
ऑटोमेटिकली एग्जीक्यूट हो जाता था और इसके
लिए यूजर से ना तो कोई परमिशन मांगी जाती
थी ना ही कोई पॉपअप आता था और इस इसी
डिफॉल्ट बिहेवियर की वजह से उस दौर में
1990 में मैक बेस्ड कंप्यूटर वायरसेस बहुत
तेजी से क्या कर रहे थे? फैल रहे थे। जो
मैक बेस वायरसेस थे वो बहुत तेजी से फैल
रहे थे उस दशक में। ऐसा क्यों?
क्योंकि
ना तो कोई वार्निंग दी जाती थी यूजर से
यूजर को ना कोई परमिशन दी जाती थी और यह
जो वीबीए है यह बहुत ज्यादा पावरफुल है।
मतलब आप कमांड लाइन वाले सारे काम वीबीए
से कर सकते हो। इफ यू डोंट नो। लिविंग ऑफ
द लैंड अटैक के बारे में अगर आप लोगों ने
सोचा है तो वह भी आप क्या कर सकते हो?
वीबीए की हेल्प से कर सकते हो। इतनी
पावरफुल है वीबीए। तो नेक्स्ट बात करते
हैं इरा टू माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ऑफिस 2003
इंट्रोडक्शन ऑफ यूजर वार्निंग अगर आप कुछ
इस तरीके से देख पा रहे हो कि इससे 2003
या 2000 7 से पहले कुछ इस तरीके की
वार्निंग देखने को मिलती थी किसके अंदर
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड के अंदर जब कोई भी फाइल
जो वीबीए इनेबल्ड जो माइक्रो फाइल थी उसको
आप एग्जीक्यूट करने की कोशिश करते तो इस
तरीके का पॉपअप आता था तो एज ऑफ Microsoft
Office 2003 दिस बिहेवियर वाज अल्टर्ड एंड
मैक्रोज़ वर नो लगर एग्जीक्यूट
एग्जीक्यूटेड ऑटोमेटिकली व्हेन ए ऑफिस
फाइल वाज़ लोडेड एंड ए जीयूआई वुड पॉप अप
इनफॉर्मिंग यूजर मै प्रेजेंस इनसाइड द
फाइल। इसका मतलब क्या है? कि Microsoft
Office ने 2003 में इस डिफॉल्ट
एग्जीक्यूशन बिहेवियर को चेंज कर दिया।
मतलब दिस बिहेवियर वाज अल्टर्ड इन 2003
2003 में जो ऑटोमेटिकली एग्जीक्यूशन था का
जो बिहेवियर था उसको चेंज कर दिया गया।
मतलब 2003 में जो मैक था जो मैक थे वह
ऑटोमेटिक रन नहीं होते थे। ठीक है? वह
ऑटोमेटिक रन नहीं होते थे। मींस व्हेन एन
ऑफिस फाइल वाज लोडेड। जब जब भी कोई
डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन होता था जब भी कोई
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एक्सेल माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड
जिसके अंदर वीबीए है ठीक है जिसके अंदर
वीबीए मौजूद है वो डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन होता था
तो जीयूआई पर यह जो आप देख पा रहे हो यह
पॉपअप यह पॉपअप वार्निंग के साथ आ जाता था
ठीक है उसकी स्क्रीन पर यह पॉपअप आ जाता
था और इसका मतलब क्या था कि इस फाइल के
अंदर वीबी मै
मैक मौजूद है। क्या आप इस फाइल को
एग्जीक्यूट करवाना चाहते हो? ओपन करना
चाहते हो या नहीं करना चाहते? देखो दिस
फाइल इज एन नेटवर्क लोकेशन। अदर यूज़र्स हु
हैव सोन सो ऐसे करके। मतलब ये किसका पॉप
अप था? मैक का पॉप अप था। अंडरस्टुड
एवरीवन?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
यह समझ में आया? नाउ कम्स टू
इरा थ्री Microsoft Office 2007 फाइल
फॉर्मेट सेपरेशन मतलब इसमें क्या हुआ?
Microsoft Office 2007 टूक माइक्रो
सिक्योरिटी ए स्टेप फदर ऑफिस Microsoft
Office 2007 में क्या किया Microsoft ने?
Microsoft ने सिक्योरिटी को एक स्टेप आगे
बढ़ाया। एक स्टेप आगे बढ़ाया। उसमें क्या
किया? माइक्रो कुड नॉट बी एंबेडेड एट ऑल
विद इन द डिफॉल्ट माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड
डॉक्यूमेंट फाइल। उन्होंने क्या स्टेप आगे
बढ़ाया? उन्होंने क्या किया? जो मैक
एंबेडेड डॉक्यूमेंट्स थे उनके लिए फाइल
एक्सटेंशन को अलग कर दिया। बिल्कुल जो
फाइल एक्सटेंशन था जैसे कि पहले डॉट डीओसी
फाइल एक्सटेंशन होता था। इसी में क्या
करते थे? दोनों आपका नॉर्मल डॉक्यूमेंट
फाइल भी इसी में अंदर आ जाते थे और दूसरा
प्लस में आपका मैक वाली भी फाइल इसी के
अंदर क्या कर दी जाती थी? एंबेड कर दी
जाती थी और पता नहीं चलता था। दोनों मिक्स
अप हो जाते थे। लेकिन 2007 के बाद
उन्होंने क्या किया कि एक तो यह जो फाइल
एक्सटेंशन था डॉट डॉक इसको क्या कर दिया?
चेंज कर दिया। आज आजकल ये फाइल एक्सटेंशन
नहीं है। ठीक है? और साथ के साथ नॉर्मल जो
फाइल थी प्लस में जो माइक्रो इनेबल फाइल
थी दोनों का फाइल एक्सटेंशन अलग-अलग कर
दिया। और यह किसके हेल्प से पॉसिबल हो
पाया? ऑफिस ओपन एक्सml स्टैंडर्ड। ऑफिस
ओपन एक्सML स्टैंडर्ड जो इंट्रोड्यूस किया
था Microsoft Office ने 2007 में। तो यह
क्या था? इसके बारे में बात करते हैं। तो
ऑफिस ओपन एक्सML स्टैंडर्ड या ओXML
द ऑफिस ओपन एक्सML स्टैंडर्ड इज ए मॉडर्न
फाइल फॉर्मेट स्टैंडर्ड इंट्रोड्यूस्ड बाय
Microsoft इन 2007 जिसको 2007 में क्या
किया गया था? इंट्रोड्यूस किया गया था।
प्रीवियसली नॉर्मल टेक्स्ट एंड मैक कोड वर
स्टड टुगेदर विद इन द सेम फाइल विदाउट एनी
स्ट्रक्चरल सेपरेशन। मतलब क्या होता था कि
पहले 2007 से पहले क्या होता था कि एक ही
फाइल के अंदर नॉर्मल टेक्स्ट भी होता था
और उसी फाइल के अंदर मैक कोड भी होता था
और दोनों को एक ही जगह बिना किसी डिफरेंस
के क्या कर दिया जाता था? मिक्स कर दिया
जाता था। मिक्स रहते थे। पर उसके बाद क्या
हुआ? जो Microsoft Office था। हाउएवर द
इंट्रोडक्शन ऑफ द ऑफिस ओपन एक्सML
स्टैंडर्ड Microsoft सेपरेटेड दी फाइल
बेस्ड ऑन देयर स्ट्रक्चर कि Microsoft ने
ऑफिस एक्सM ऑफिस ओपन एक्सML स्टैंडर्ड की
हेल्प से क्या किया कि जो स्ट्रक्चर व जो
नॉर्मल डॉक्यूमेंट है और जो आपका मैनेबल
डॉक्यूमेंट है दोनों को स्ट्रक्चर वाइज
क्या कर दिया डिफरेंस कर दिया अलग कर दिया
जैसे जैसे कि डॉट डॉक्स डॉक एक्स डॉट
एक्सlx ये क्या है? डिफॉल्ट एक्सML बेस
फॉर्मेट है। यह क्या सपोर्ट नहीं करता?
वीबीए मै सपोर्ट नहीं करता। आप इसके अंदर
क्या कर सकते क्या नहीं कर सकते? मैक
एंबेड नहीं कर सकते। एंबेड कर सकते हो बट
यह मैक एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होगा। दूसरा है
डॉक एम और एक्सेल है। यह क्या है? यह
नॉर्मल आपका MS Word का है।
वर्ड के लिए यह क्या है? आपका एक्सेल के
लिए। यह Excel के लिए। ठीक है? यह आपका
Excel के लिए। यह दोनों क्या है? देखो,
अगर पीछे X है, तो आपके नॉर्मल नॉर्मल
फ़ॉर्मेट है। अगर पीछे M लगा दिया, तो ये
क्या है? मैक इनेबल डोकन फॉर्मेट है।
इसमें क्या कर सकते हो आप? अपने मैक्रोज़
को स्टोर भी कर सकते हो और एग्जीक्यूट भी
कर सकते हो। तो, अगर मैं आपको दिखा देता
हूं। यह कुछ फॉर्मेट है। देखो, यह रहा
docx स्टैंडर्ड XML फॉर्मेट। इसमें मै
एंबेडेड अलाउड नहीं है।
यह क्या है? टेंपलेट के लिए एक फ़ॉर्मेट्स
कंप्रेस टेंपल्लेट स्टैंडर्ड एक्सml
टेंपलेट इसके अंदर भी क्या अलाउड नहीं है?
डॉट एक्स के अंदर भी आपका एंबेडेड मैक
अलाउड नहीं है। डॉ एम और डॉट एम दोनों के
अंदर क्या अलाउड है? आपका मैक अलाउड है।
मतलब अगर इस इन दोनों फाइल एक्सटेंशन के
साथ अगर आप मै कोड लिखोगे, पेलोड लिखोगे
और उसको यूजर के पास भेज दोगे और वह क्लिक
करता है। उस वार्निंग को भी क्लिक करता है
तो क्या होगा? फिर क्या होगा? आपका मैक
एग्जीक्यूट होगा। अदरवाइज आपका मैक
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होगा। तो
नाउ अभी इस सेपरेशन का फायदा क्या हुआ?
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट ने 2007 में जब ऑफिस ओपन
एक्सm स्टैंडर्ड को बनाया जिसने स्ट्रक्चर
वाइज दोनों को अलग कर दिया तो इस सेपरेशन
का फायदा क्या हुआ? तो सबसे पहला फायदा
हुआ इसका बिल्ट इन प्रोटेक्शन। बिल्ट इन
प्रोटेक्शन यह फायदा हुआ। मतलब क्या है कि
अगर आप किसी डॉक एक्स फाइल को इस वाली
फाइल एक्सटेंशन को क्या करोगे?
मैक के साथ रन करने की कोशिश करोगे तो
क्या होगा? जो आपका ओपन एक्सML स्टैंडर्ड
का जो स्ट्रक्चर है जो फॉर्मेट
स्ट्रक्चर्स है आपका वो इसको क्या
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होने देगा। इस वाले फाइल
फॉर्मेट में अगर आप एग्जीक्यूट करने की
कोशिश करोगे मैक को इसके अंदर मैक कोड
लिखकर तो वह एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होगा। दूसरा
लेगसी वर्सेस मॉडर्न फॉर्मेट मतलब क्या
है? कि अगर हम बात करते हैं लेगसी फाइल की
अगर डॉट डॉक फाइल है मतलब 97 ऑफिस 97 टू
2003 के टाइम की तो अगर इस टाइप की फाइल
किसी को भेजी जाती है अगर आपको इस टाइप की
फाइल मिलती है तो उसमें हायर चांसेस है कि
उसके अंदर मैक इनेबल हो सकता है एज ए
डिफेंसिव पर साइड में बता देता हूं आपको
अगर आपको डॉट डॉक ओनली डॉट डॉक फाइल देखने
को मिलती है। आपके पास कोई ऐसी फाइल भेजता
है नाउ ए डज़। इसका मतलब इसके अंदर क्या
है? हाई रिस्क है। इसके अंदर आपका जो मैक
कोड है उसका एग्जीक्यूशन हाइड हो सकता है।
हालांकि जो मॉडर्न डॉक एक्स फाइल है उसके
अंदर आप मैक एंबेड नहीं कर सकते। वह मैक
को सपोर्ट नहीं करता। वार्निंग आता है
उसको ड्यूरिंग एग्जीक्यूशन। ड्यूरिंग
एग्जीक्यूशन।
ड्यूरिंग उसमें क्या आता है? वार्निंग आता
है। नेक्स्ट तीसरा बेनिफिट क्या हुआ?
तीसरा बेनिफिट यह हुआ प्रोटेक्टेड व्यू।
टुडे व्हेन यू ओपन ए माइक्रो इनेबल्ड फाइल
Microsoft Office ऑटोमेटिकली ओपन्स इन
प्रोटेक्टेड व्यू। तो तीसरा सबसे बड़ा
फायदा क्या होता है? आजकल जब भी आप
माइक्रो इनेबल्ड फाइल ओपन करते हो तो
Microsoft Office उसको क्या करता है? एक
प्रोटेक्टेड व्यू में ओपन करता है। इस
तरीके से देखोगे कि अभी इसके ऊपर आप कुछ
भी नहीं कर सकते। जब तक इसके ऊपर क्लिक
नहीं करोगे। इनेबल कंटेंट नहीं करोगे यहां
पर जब तक आप इसके अंदर कुछ भी नहीं कर
सकते। जैसे इनेबल कंटेंट करोगे तभी आप
क्या कर पाओगे? वो कोड भी रन कर पाओगे।
बाकी काम कर पाओगे। मतलब क्या कर रहा है
कि अगर किसी फाइल के अंदर मैक है और मैक
होने के बाद किसी फाइल के अंदर क्या है?
अगर मैक है और आप उसको ओपन करने की कोशिश
करोगे तो क्या होगा? बाय डिफ़ॉल्ट
प्रोटेक्टेड व्यू में ओपन होगा और जब तक
उसको एक्सप्लसिटली आप उसको इनेबल कंटेंट
को क्लिक नहीं करते तब तक वो वो
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होगा। यह तीसरा फायदा था
किसका? उस सेपरेशन का। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
यह सबको समझ में आया?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
यह सबको समझ में आ गया?
जल्दी से यस या नो चैट में बताओ। यहां तक
सबको क्लियर है?
डोंट वरी। आज का लास्ट मेरे ख्याल से
थ्योरी पार्ट इसके लिए मैक्रो से रिलेटेड
मे भी आज लास्ट है। जो नेक्स्ट क्लास होगी
कल की उसमें प्रैक्टिकल्स पर हम शिफ्ट हो
जाएंगे।
यह मैं बताऊंगा एनोनिमस। यही तो चीज है ना
जो प्रैक्टिकली मैं आपको बताऊंगा। डोंट
वरी हां मैं बताऊंगा।
आजकल भी ये बहुत कम यूज़ होता है। बट मैं
आपको बताऊंगा कैसे आप यूज़ कर सकते हो।
होता है फाइल एक्सटेंशन अलग कर दी है। नाउ
ए डेज क्या है कि आप नॉर्मल एक साथ एक ही
फाइल में मर्ज नहीं कर सकते। फाइल
एक्सटेंशन अलग कर दिया। इसकी ट्रिक है।
कैसे मैं आपको बताऊं।
हां इनेबल करना पड़ता तब भी करना पड़ता
आजकल ये क्या है प्रोटेक्टेड उसको जब जैसे
लगता है वर्ड को तो वो इनेबल ही करवाता है
तो बाय डिफॉल्ट तो नॉर्मली क्या इनेबल
करना पड़ता तो है यह आजकल है पहले नहीं था
ऐसा कोई फीचर तो चलिए फिर और किसी कोई और
डाउट
यह सिक्योरिटी फीचर्स है इसका।
किसी को और डाउट आगे चलें। आगे बढ़े
बताइए। आगे बढ़े दोस्तों।
चलिए तो अभी हम बात करते हैं
Microsoft Office फाइल फॉर्मेट। नाउ लेट
अस अंडरस्टैंड हाउ Microsoft Word हैंडल द
फाइल फॉर्मेट। कि जो Microsoft Word है वो
फाइल फॉर्मेट को कैसे हैंडल करता है? चलिए
देखते हैं। तो Microsoft Word यूजज़ फाइल
एक्सटेंशन टू डिटरमाइन द सॉफ्टवेयर दैट
विल हैंडल द ओपनिंग ऑफ ए फाइल वंस इट इज
कलेक्ट। वंस इट इज कलेक्ट। क्या मेरी आवाज
नहीं आ रही है सबको? बताना जरा।
हेलो गाइज़, सबको आवाज आ रही है?
सबको आवाज आ रही है? बाकी लोग बताइए। जगत
गुरु जी अब्दुल नो
ओके तो आप अपनी साइड देखिए लड़के
ओके तो microsoft वर्ड यूज फाइल एक्सटेंशन
टू डिटरमाइन द सॉफ्टवेयर दैट विल हैंडल द
ओपनिंग ऑफ ए फाइल वंस इट इज क्लिक इसका
मतलब क्या है कि Windows फाइल एक्सटेंशन
का यूज करके
Windows फाइल एक्सटेंशन का यूज करके
सॉरी सॉरी मेरा कुछ नोट्स थे। आई डोंट एक
वेट वेट गाइस।
ओके हां आई एम रिपीटिंग। आगे जो लाइन है
कि Microsoft Windows यूजज़ फाइल एक्सटेंशन
टू डिटरमाइन द सॉफ्टवेयर दैट विल हैंडल द
ओपनिंग ऑफ ए फाइल वंस इट इज़ इट वाज़
इट इज़ क्लिक। इसका मतलब क्या है कि जो
Windows है जो Microsoft Window है वह
फाइल एक्सटेंशन का यूज करके यह डिटरमाइन
करता है कि जब यूजर किसी फाइल पर डबल
क्लिक करें तो उसको कौन सा सॉफ्टवेयर
हैंडल करेगा। फाइल एक्सटेंशन सबसे पहले
क्या डिसाइड करवाता है? जैसे आप उस पर डबल
क्लिक करते हो तो उस फाइल को कौन सा
सॉफ्टवेयर हैंडल करेगा? यह डिटरमाइन करता
है Microsoft Window बेस्ड ऑन द फाइल
एक्सटेंशन। बाय द टाइम Microsoft Office
इज इंस्टॉल्ड। दी अबोव एक्सटेंशनंस आर
एसोसिएटेड विद इट एंड सब्सक्वेंटली ऑल ऑफ
द फाइल टाइप्स विल बी हैंडल्ड बाय
Microsoft Office सूट ऑफ ए ऑफ प्रोग्राम।
मतलब जब आप सिस्टम में Microsoft Office
इंस्टॉल करते हो तो जितने भी एक्सटेंशन
मैंने आपको बताया वो बाय डिफॉल्ट
Microsoft Office Swift के साथ क्या होते
हैं? एसोसिएट हो जाते हैं। उसके साथ आ
जाते हैं और उन सारे फाइल एक्सटेंशन को जो
Microsoft Office स्विच है जो एक्सेल है,
वर्ड है या आपका एक्सेस है, आउटलुक है,
पीपेटेज है वो ऑटोमेटिकली उसी पर्टिकुलर
फाइल एक्सटेंशन को उसका जिससे रिलेशन है
फाइल एक्शन के साथ वो उसको ऑटोमेटिकली
हैंडल करते हैं। वो ऑटोमेटिकली हैंडल करते
हैं। अब सबसे पहले हम क्या करते हैं? एक
बहुत बड़ा मिस कांसेप्ट क्लियर करते हैं।
और वो मिसकंसेप्ट क्या है कि अक्सर
ज्यादातर क्या लोग सोचते हैं कि क्या होगा
अगर हम एक डॉक एम फाइल जिसके अंदर मैक है
उसका उसकी एक्सटेंशन को रीनेम करके डॉक
एक्स कर दें मतलब ये डॉक एम फाइल है मैंने
क्या किया इसके अंदर मैक है इसका जो
एक्सटेंशन था डॉट डॉ एम इसको चेंज कर दिया
और doc एक्स कर दिया तो क्या फाइल खुले
खुलेगी
और मै एग्जीक्यूट होगा।
क्या वह फाइल खुलेगी और मैक एग्जीक्यूट
होगा? बताइए आप लोग क्या वो फाइल खुलेगी
और मैक एग्जीक्यूट होगा? आप लोग बताइए आप
लोगों को क्या लगता है? वो फाइल खुलने
वाली है।
इसका आंसर है नहीं। वह फाइल नहीं खुलेगी।
इसका कारण है माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड का फाइल
डाटा वैलिडेशन प्रोसेस। अगर आप डॉ एम का
एक्सटेंशन चेंज करके doc एक्स रख देते हो
और उसके अंदर मैक कोड लिखा हुआ है तो क्या
होगा कि वह फाइल क्या करेगी?
खुलेगी लेकिन वह एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होगा।
खुलेगी एग्जीक्यूट नहीं होगा वह या करप्ट
हो जाएगी वह नहीं खुलेगी क्योंकि जो
Microsoft Word है वह एक वैलिडेशन प्रोसेस
का यूज़ करता है। एक डेटा वैलिडेशन प्रोसेस
का यूज़ करता है। तो वो कौन सी है वैलिडेशन
प्रोसेस? वो है Microsoft Word परफॉर्म्स
फाइल डाटा वैलिडेशन प्रेयर टू ओपनिंग ए
फाइल। प्रेयर टू ओपनिंग ए फाइल। एंड डाटा
वैलिडेशन इज परफॉर्म इन द फॉर्म ऑफ डाटा
स्ट्रक्चर आइडेंटिफिकेशन अगेंस्ट द ऑफिस
ओपन एक्सml स्टैंडर्ड मतलब क्या है? जब भी
आप Microsoft फॉर एग्जांपल वर्ड का लेते
हैं। जब भी आप Microsoft Word में कोई भी
फाइल ओपन करते हो तो जो Microsoft Office
जो वर्ड है वो फाइल के एक्सटेंशन पर
ब्लाइंडली ट्रस्ट नहीं करता। ब्लाइंडली
Reliance नहीं करता। जो Microsoft Word है
वह इंटरनली डाटा स्ट्रक्चर को क्या करता
है? आइडेंटिफाई और वैलिडेट करता है। किसके
अगेंस्ट? ऑफिस ओपन एक्सml स्टैंडर्ड। जो
ऑफिस ओपन एक्सml स्टैंडर्ड है इसके
अगेंस्ट क्या किया जाता है? इसका जो
स्ट्रक्चर्स है उसको आइडेंटिफाई और
वैलिडेट किया जाता है। एंड द वैलिडेशन इज
एक्चुअली परफॉर्म्ड बाय Microsoft Office
www lbdl यह एक लाइब्रेरी है एक कंपोनेंट
है जिसके द्वारा यह वैलिडेशन परफॉर्म किया
जाता है। यह लाइब्रेरी रिस्पांसिबल है जो
इसका वैलिडेशन परफॉर्म करती है उस फाइल का
एंड द फाइल नेम एक्सटेंशन प्ले नो रोल ऑन
दिस डाटा वैलिडेशन प्रोसेस और एक बात बता
देता हूं कि जो फाइल नेम है जो फाइल नेम
एक्सटेंशन है वो डेटा वैलिडेशन प्रोसेस
में कोई भी रोल प्ले नहीं करता। उसका अपना
अलग रोल है। बट डाटा वैलिडेशन प्रोसेस में
उसका कोई भी रोल नहीं है। इफ एनी एरर
अकर्स ड्यूरिंग द डेटा स्ट्रक्चर
आइडेंटिफिकेशन दी फाइल बीइंग एनालाइज्ड
एंड विल नॉट बी ओपन। मतलब जब यह लाइब्रेरी
फाइल की जो जो इंटरनल स्ट्रक्चर्स है जो
उसके हेडर्स है उनको रीड करती है और
आइडेंटिफिकेशन के दौरान किसी डाटा
स्ट्रक्चर में मिसमैच मिलता है या एरर आती
है तो वह फाइल ओपन नहीं होगी। वो फाइल ओपन
नहीं होगी। मतलब इसका सीधा मतलब यह है कि
इसका सीधा मतलब यह है कि एक्सटेंशन बदलने
से वैलिडेशन बाईपास नहीं होगा। अगर आप
किसी फाइल का एक्सटेंशन बदल दोगे उससे
वैलिडेशन बाईपास नहीं होगा। अगर आपने doc
m को doc एक्स कर दिया तो आपको लगेगा कि
आपने सिक्योरिटी को बाईपास कर लिया। आपने
Microsoft को उल्लू बना दिया। Microsoft
को पागल बना दिया। लेकिन ऐसा नहीं है।
Microsoft इतनी आसानी से बेवकूफ नहीं
बनता।
वह क्या करता है? वह फाइल खोलते वक्त क्या
करता है? आपका जो नाम है और जो एक्सटेंशन
है सब सिंगल उस पर भरोसा नहीं करता बल्कि
फाइल के अंदर जो रियल स्ट्रक्चर्स है उसको
भी इंस्पेक्ट करता है। ओनली फाइल
एक्सटेंशन के बेस पर आपको अलाउ नहीं करता।
मतलब उसके अंदर जो स्ट्रक्चर्स है उसको
वैलिडेट करता है। देन ओनली वो फाइल क्या
की जाती है? ओपन होती है। तभी वह फाइल
क्या होती है? ओपन होती है। तो थोड़ा चलो
भाई फाइल एक्सटेंशन पर भी नजर डाल लेते
हैं। तो फाइल एक्सटेंशन फॉर एग्जांपल doc
एक्स और डॉ एम सिंपली इंस्ट्रक्ट द विंडोज
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स ऑन वि प्रोग्राम टू
यूज़ व्हेन यू डबल क्लिक ए फाइल। मतलब जो
फाइल एक्सटेंशनंस है वो दो पर्पज से यूज
किया जाता है। पहला पर्पज क्या है कि
जो Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम्स है ठीक है
जो पहला पर्पज यह है कि Microsoft मतलब
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को यह बताया जाता
है कि जब उस फाइल पर डबल क्लिक होता है तो
उस एक्सटेंशन के बेस पर यह डिसीजन लिया
जाता है कि इस फाइल को कौन ओपन करेगा।
जैसे Docx को MS Word ओपन करेगा। PDF को
AOब रीडर ऑन ओपन करेगा। पहला तो यह यह काम
है फाइल एक्सटेंशन का। दूसरा क्या है कि
जो यूज़र्स है
जो यूज़र्स है यह यूज़र्स के लिए इंडिकेटर
का काम करता है। यह यूज़र्स के लिए भी क्या
करता है? इंडिकेटर का काम करता है। मतलब
कि यूजर बाहर से इस फाइल को देख के बता
देगा कि इसके अंदर क्या हो सकता है। आप
फाइल एक्सटेंशन देख के ही बताओगे ना कि
ओके ये वर्ड की फाइल है। ये एक्सेल की
फाइल है। ये पीडीएफ फाइल है। ये आपकी
hटीएमl फाइल है। ये सीएसएस फाइल है। ये
जावास्क्रिप्ट फाइल है। ये पीएपी फाइल है।
ये पython फाइल है। ये सी फाइल है। ये
सारी चीज़ आप तभी बताते हो क्योंकि आप फाइल
एक्सटेंशन देखते हो। और फाइल एक्सटेंशन के
बेस पे तो आप बता पाते हैं ना इस टाइप की
फाइल है। यह सिर्फ दो ही काम के लिए फाइल
एक्सटेंशन का यूज किया जाता है। दोनों एक
तो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को बताने के लिए दूसरा
हम यूज़र्स हैं। हम भी आइडेंटिफाई कर पाए
कि ये किस टाइप की फाइल हो सकती है।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन? फाइल एक्सटेंशन का
पर्पज। फाइल एक्सटेंशन का पर्पस।
अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
अंडरस्टुड समझ में आया?
बताइए
बाकी दो ही लोगों को समझ में आया बाकी लोग
दो तो चार लोगों को समझ में आया बाकी
ओके पांच बाकी
चलिए मैं समझा देता हूं अभी एक और चीज को
जब आप आप क्या करते हो? यहां मैंने
इंग्लिश में लिखा। मैं आपको हिंदी में बता
देता हूं। जब भी आप क्या करते हो? किसी भी
फाइल के ऊपर डबल क्लिक करते हो। ठीक है?
फॉर एग्जांपल एक वर्ड फाइल है। एक वर्ड
फाइल है। फॉर एग्जांपल एक ये वर्ड फाइल
आपकी
डॉट
गो एक्स एक आपकी यह वर्ड फाइल है। ठीक है?
तो जब आपने इस पर डबल क्लिक किया और जैसे
ही डबल क्लिक करते हो तो इसको कौन हैंडल
करेगा? Microsoft Word हैंडल करेगा। इस
फाइल को कौन हैंडल करेगा? Microsoft Word
हैंडल करेगा। और जब Microsoft Word हैंडल
करता है तो जैसे ही वो फाइल Microsoft
Word के पास जाती है क्योंकि जैसे क्लिक
किया Microsoft Word प्रोसेस को मिल गई।
तो वो क्या करता है? उसका इंटरनल पार्सल
क्या होता है? एक्टिवेट होता है। जो
इंटरनल पार्सलर है उस फाइल को रीड करता
है। और रीड फाइल रीड करने के बाद वह क्या
नोटिस करता है? वह चेक करता है कि ओके
एक्सटेंशन तो डॉक एक्स है बट इसके अंदर
वीबीए मैक एंबेड किया हुआ छुपाया गया है
इसके अंदर एक्सटेंशन तो इसका डॉक एक्स है
लेकिन इसके अंदर वीबीए मै को क्या किया
गया है एंबेड किया गया है अब microsoft जो
वर्ड है वो देखता है कि जो एक्सटेंशन है
डॉक एक्स ठीक है उसका मतलब क्या है कि मैं
माइक्रो कोड को सपोर्ट नहीं करता जो जो मै
माइक्रो एंबेड कोड है। मैं उसको सपोर्ट
नहीं करता। मैं उसके लिए एग्जीक्यूशन
परफॉर्म नहीं करता। ठीक है? और लेकिन इसके
अंदर तो मै कोड है। तो इसलिए क्या हुआ? जो
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड है वो इस फाइल को क्या
बोलता है? मिसमाइज मिसमैच बोल देता है या
इनवैलिड फाइल बोल देता है या करप्टेड फाइल
बोल देता है या करप्टेड फाइल मान लेता है।
बिकॉज़ क्योंकि क्योंकि एक्सटेंशन डॉक एक्स
है। ठीक है? लेकिन उसके अंदर मैक कोड
प्रेजेंट है। इसलिए क्या हुआ? जो उसकी
स्ट्रक्चर्स है वो मिसमैच हो गई और वहीं
पर एरर आ गई। वहीं पर एरर आ गई। तो, यह
होती है वह कहानी। यहीं पर आपकी एरर आ गई।
तो, नेक्स्ट चलते हैं हम अपनी नेक्स्ट
पॉइंट पर कि इट शुड नॉट बी इट शुड नॉट बी
दैट सॉरी सॉरी आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट।
इट शुड नॉट बी इट शुड बी नोटेड दैट डॉक एम
फाइल कंटेनिंग मैक्रोस कैन बी रिनेम्ड एज
अदर फाइल फॉर्मेट बाय चेंजिंग द फाइल
एक्सटेंशन एंड स्टिल कीपिंग देयर मै
एग्जीक्यूटिंग कैपेबिलिटीज
मतलब यह है कि
फॉर एग्जांपल एन आरटीएफ फाइल डज नॉट
सपोर्ट मैक्रोस बाय डिजोन बाय डिज़ ए डॉक
एम फाइल रिनेम टू आरटीएफ विल बी हैंडल्ड
बाय माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड एंड विल बी कैपेबल
ऑफ मैक एग्जीक्यूशन। इसका मतलब मैं समझा
देता हूं।
अगर हम हिस्टोरिकली बात करें जो डॉक एम
फाइल थी। ठीक है? अगर आप उसका एक्सटेंशन
चेंज करके जो डॉक एम फाइल थी ये रही।
हिस्टोरिकली बात करते हैं जो डॉ एम फाइल
थी। अगर आप इसका एक्सटेंशन चेंज करके क्या
रख देते हो? RTF
RTF अब ये आरटीएफ एक्सटेंशन क्या है? रिच
टेक्स्ट फॉर्मेट। यह क्या है आपका? रिच
टेक्स्ट फॉर्मेट। तो क्या होता था? बाय
डिज़ाइन जो आरटीएफ फाइल थी, यह मै को जो
मैक है उसको सपोर्ट नहीं करती। बाय डिज़ यह
मैक को सपोर्ट नहीं करती। बाय यानी क्या
नहीं करती? मैक को
सपोर्ट नहीं करता। बाय डिजाइन इसको सपोर्ट
नहीं करता। लेकिन जब आप क्या करते थे जो
डॉ एम है doc mm फाइल को आरtएफ में क्या
कर देते थे? कन्वर्ट कर देते थे। उसका जो
रिनेम कर देते थे। उस फाइल नेम एक्सटेंशन
को चेंज कर देते थे। और जैसे आप इसके ऊपर
क्या करते थे? आपने क्या किया? डबल क्लिक।
जैसे आपने इसके ऊपर डबल क्लिक किया।
जैसे आपने इसके ऊपर डबल क्लिक किया। डबल
क्लिक करते ही क्या होता था? इसको कौन
हैंडल करता था? इसको हैंडल करता था MS
Word। इसको कौन हैंडल करता था? MS Word
इसको हैंडल करता था भैया हमारा MS Word।
इसको हैंडल करता था हमारा MS Word। ओके?
और MS Word को कॉल किया जाता था। और जैसे
MS Word क्या करता था? MS Word जब इस फाइल
को प्रोसेस करता था। जब MS Word इस फाइल
को प्रोसेस करता है तो वह देखता है कि
इसके अंदर तो मैक स्ट्रक्चर प्रेजेंट है।
इसके अंदर क्या प्रेजेंट है? डॉक एम
प्रेजेंट है। मतलब मैक स्ट्रक्चर प्रेजेंट
है। और मैक वो क्या करता है? इसको ब्लॉक
नहीं करता था। वह इसमें क्या कर देता था?
मैक एग्जीक्यूशन को इनेबल रखता था। मैक जो
एग्जीक्यूशन है जो मैक एग्जीक्यूशन है
उसको क्या करता था इनेबल रखता था मै
एग्जीक्यूशन को इनेबल मैं रिपीट कर देता
हूं कि जब आपने क्या किया जो एम फाइल को
रिनेम करके आरtएफ कर दिया और उस फाइल पर
डबल क्लिक किया डबल क्लिक करते ही Windows
उस उस फाइल को हैंडल करने के लिए
Microsoft Word को देता है और Microsoft
Word उस फाइल को जब प्रोसेस करता है तो वो
देखता है कि उसके अंदर DC M प्रेजेंट है
मतलब मै स्ट्रक्चर्स है। उसके अंदर मैक
कोड प्रेजेंट है और उस फाइल को वो रीड
करता है। करप्ट नहीं करता रीड करता है और
रीड करके जो मैक एग्जीक्यूशन है उसको
इनेबल रखता है। उसको ब्लॉक नहीं करता।
उसको ब्लॉक नहीं करता। मतलब क्या है कि जो
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड है जब उस फाइल को
प्रोसेस करता है तो वो उसके अंदर जो
माइक्रो स्ट्रक्चर्स है उसको चुपचाप रीड
कर लेता है और मैक एग्जीक्यूशन को एक्टिव
रखता है। मतलब हैकर ने क्या किया? बस एक
एक्सटेंशन बदल के सिक्योरिटी को आसानी से
बाईपास कर लेता है। यह होता था। यह होता
था 2007 के बाद भी होता था। ठीक है? 2016
तक ये चीज होती थी। मतलब डॉग कैंप को अगर
डॉट आरtएफ एक्सटेंशन में कन्वर्ट कर दिया
जाता था। तो ये क्या हो जाता था जो
सिक्योरिटी बायपास हो जाती थी और जो आपका
जो MS Word है चुपचाप उस मै फाइल को रीड
भी करता था। उसको एग्जीक्यूट भी करता था।
इससे क्या होता है जो हैकर्स है उस
सिक्योरिटी को बायपास कर लेते। लेकिन आजकल
के जो भी मॉडर्न ऑफिससेस हैं आज का जो भी
मॉडर्न ऑफिसिसेस है MS Word
2016 MS Word 2016 और उसके बाद
क्या करते हैं? वो एक पॉलिसी फॉलो करते
हैं। स्ट्रिक्ट फाइल फॉर्मेट चेक। कौन सी?
स्ट्रिक्ट
स्ट्रिक्ट फाइल
फॉर्मेट चेक। HTFC बोल सकते हो उसको।
स्ट्रिक्ट फाइल फॉर्मेट चेक मतलब
स्ट्रिक्ट वैलिडेशन उन्होंने लगा दिया। अब
कोई चांस नहीं है कि आप चाहे वो एक्सटेंशन
को चेंज करो, कुछ भी करो वो काम नहीं
करेगी। इससे पहले होता था बट अब वो ऐसा
नहीं होता। Microsoft
Word जो Microsoft Office 2016 है उससे
पहले में यह ट्रिक थी काम करती थी। लेकिन
अब यह ट्रिक काम नहीं करती। अंडरस्टुड
एवरीवन? अंडरस्टुड?
नॉर्मल रिच टेक्स्ट फॉर्मेट यह कोई
टेक्स्ट फॉर्मेट ही होता था
आरटीएफ फाइल नॉर्मल टेक्स्ट फॉर्मेट ही
होता था बट उसके अंदर आप उसका क्या करते
आरटीएफ फाइल कर देते थे तो उसको प्रोसेस
होता था उससे बाईपास हो जाता था
अंडरस्टुड
आगे बढ़े
या
बोर हो रहे हो बता दूं
कि उसके बाद भी काफी बच गया है बोलोगे तो
थ्योरी है तो मे बी अराउंड 25 30 मिनट की
थ्योरी है तो अगर आप बोलोगे तो नेक्स्ट
में कर सकता हूं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
क्योंकि चीजें आपको समझानी है मेरे को
जल्दी बताओ
बताइए बताइए मैं जो परमानेंट स्टूडेंट आते
हैं डेली बेसिस पे उनका मायने ज्यादा रखता
है मेरे लिए
कवर करना है।
चलिए फिर
नेक्स्ट हमारा टॉपिक है डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट
एंड वीबीए
हम वीबीए मैक के बारे में फंडामेंटल कवर
कर रहे हैं ब्रो। तो देखिए अब बात करते
हैं डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट एंड वीबीए
इंटीग्रेशन। तो अब हमारा जो हमारा टेक्निक
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक है हमारा डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
एंड वीबीए। ठीक है? तो सबसे पहले हम एक
फंडामेंटल कंफ्यूजन दूर करते हैं। तो
फंडामेंटल कंफ्यूजन क्या है कि डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट इज नॉट वीबीए।
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट इज नॉट वीबीए। यह वीबीए
नहीं है। यह कंफ्यूजन बिल्कुल रखना कि यह
वीबीए नहीं है।
इज नॉट वीबीए। दिस इज अ फंडामेंटल
कंफ्यूजन। तो यह एक चीज याद रखना कि जो
डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट है वह आपका वीबीए नहीं
है। याद रहेगा सबको डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट को
वीबीए बोलने की कोशिश मत करना। यह अलग चीज
है और यही आपका सबसे पावरफुल हथियार है
आपके इसका पेलोड एग्जीक्यूशन का या आपके
पेलोड डिजाइन का।
ओके? तो चलिए तो डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट एंड
वीबीए इंटीग्रेशन की बात करते हैं।
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट इज एंड स्क्रिप्ट होस्ट
ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल दैट प्रोवाइड्स ए
स्क्रिप्टिंग एनवायरमेंट फॉर
एग्जीक्यूटिंग स्क्रिप्ट ऑन Windows बेस्ड
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। जो डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट
जिसको हम Windows स्क्रिप्ट होस्ट भी
बोलते हैं। यह Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का
एक ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल है और स्क्रिप्टिंग
एनवायरमेंट है। एक ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल और
स्क्रिप्टिंग एनवायरमेंट है। क्या-क्या
है? ये एक ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल और एक
स्क्रिप्टिंग एनवायरमेंट है। ओके? तो अभी
एक चीज याद रखना कि जो Windows में दो तरह
के काम होते हैं। Windows में दो तरह के
काम होते हैं। पहला होता है आपका जीयूआई
से। पहला काम होता है आपका जीयूआई से और
दूसरा काम होता है आपका सीएलआई से। दूसरा
काम होता है आपका सीएलआई से। जीआई से कैसे
होता है? किसी फाइल पर आपने डबल क्लिक
किया, फोल्डर ओपन किया, एप्लीकेशन को ओपन
किया, काम करना स्टार्ट कर दिया। सीएलआईएस
पर क्या करते हो आप? ऑटोमेटिक काम करवाते
हो, कमांड लिखते हो, कोड लिखते हो,
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ऑटोमेटिकली उसको किसी
पर्टिकुलर टाइम फ्रेम के बाद या
ऑटोमेटिकली उसको परफॉर्म करता रहता है। तो
Windows पर या किसी भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पर
ज्यादातर दो ही टाइप के काम होते हैं। जो
जिसमें जीयूआई नहीं है, उसमें सीएलआई बेस
कम होता है। लेकिन जिसमें जीयूआई इनवॉल्व
है ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफ़ेस। तो जहां पर
Window की बात करें तो Windows पर दो
तरीके के ज्यादा काम होते हैं। कौन सा?
जीयूआई पर और सीएलआई पर। ओके? अब नॉर्मल
यूज़र्स के लिए जो ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफ़ेस
वो सही है। लेकिन जो सिस्टम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स होते हैं, जो
प्रोग्रामर्स होते हैं जिनको
डेली लाइफ में जो रोजमर्रा के हजारों काम
करने के लिए ऑटोमेशन की रिक्वायरमेंट होती
है। तो उसके लिए क्या करते हैं? वे
यूज करते हैं किसका? डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट का
या जो डेवलपर्स है जो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स है
उनके हजारों काम को ऑटोमेटिकली परफॉर्म
करवाने के लिए के लिए जो Microsoft है
उसने Windows स्क्रिप्ट होस्ट को डिजाइन
किया। Windows स्क्रिप्ट होस्ट को बनाया।
तो यह क्या करता है? इट अलाउस यूजर टू रन
स्क्रिप्ट रिटर्न इन स्क्रिप्टिंग
लैंग्वेज सच एज वी स्क्रिप्ट एंड
जेस्क्रिप्ट डायरेक्टली फ्रॉम द क्लाइंट
कमांड लाइन और एज पार्ट ऑफ ऑटोमेटेड
प्रोसेस मतलब क्या है कि किसी भी यूजर को
विंडोज पर स्क्रिप्ट्स लाइक वीबी
स्क्रिप्ट जिसका एक्सटेंशन क्या हो सकता
है डॉट वीबीएस या jस्क्रिप्ट जिसको हम
जावास्क्रिप्ट बोलते हैं डॉट जेएस को
डायरेक्ट कमांड लाइन से या ओएस लेवल पर
एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए अलव करता है। मतलब
क्या है कि जो डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है किसी
भी यूजर को Windows पर डायरेक्ट कमांड
लाइन या ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लेवल पर
एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए अलऊ करता है। और
जो डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है वो Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर एक बिल्ड इन
प्रोग्राम होता है। ठीक है? एक बिल्ड इन
प्रोग्राम होता है। आपका जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है वह एक बिल्ड इन
प्रोग्राम होता है जिसको बाहर से इंस्टॉल
नहीं करना पड़ता।
ठीक है? जिसको बाहर से इंस्टॉल नहीं करना
पड़ता। ठीक है? अब यह क्या करता है?
क्योंकि जो आपका कंप्यूटर है जो आपका
कंप्यूटर है वह कभी भी
जो आपका यह एक्सटेंशन है वीबीएस और दूसरा
एक्सटेंशन कौन सा है? जेएस
इसके अंदर जो भी टेक्स्ट कोड लिखा रहता है
इन एक्सटेंशन के अंदर जो भी स्क्रिप्ट
लिखी होती है इसके अंदर जो भी टेक्स्ट
लिखे रहते हैं उसको नहीं समझता आपका जो
कंप्यूटर है इन दोनों एक्सटेंशंस के अंदर
जो भी इंग्लिश आपने लिखी है जो भी कोड
लिखा है वो नहीं समझता तो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट क्या करता है
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट पहले इन फाइल्स को रीड
करता है इनके एक-एक कमांड एक-एक कोड को
क्या करता है पढ़ता है ट्रांसलेट करता है
और फिर क्या होता है कोड को पढ़ने के बाद
जो डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट है जो डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट है Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम को
इंस्ट्रक्शन देता है कि भैया स्क्रीन पर
पॉपअप दिखाना है फोल्डर बनाना है या
एप्लीकेशन ल्च करना है। आई मीन कि जो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट है वह क्या करता है?
डायरेक्ट कमांड लाइन और ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
लेवल पर एग्जीक्यूट करता है और जो आपका
कंप्यूटर है वह डॉट वो जो जावास्क्रिप्ट
फॉर्मेट है या जो आपका वीबी स्क्रिप्ट
फॉर्मेट है इसको नहीं समझता। तो
डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट क्या करता है? पहले उस
फाइल को रीड करता है। उसके अंदर के कोड को
समझता है। उसको ट्रांसलेट करता है।
ट्रांसलेट करने के बाद Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम को इंस्ट्रक्शन देता है कि स्क्रीन
पर क्या करना है? उस कोड में अगर यह बोला
है कि आपको एक स्क्रीन पर पॉपअप दिखाना है
तो पॉपअप दिखाया जाएगा। अगर एक फोल्डर
बनाना है तो फोल्डर बनाया जाएगा या किसी
एप्लीकेशन को ल्च करना है तो उस एप्लीकेशन
को ल्च किया जाएगा विद दी हेल्प ऑफ दिस
डब्ल्यू इस कोड की हेल्प से नाउ इन द
कॉन्टेक्स्ट ऑफ वीबीए विजुअल बेसिक्स फॉर
एप्लीकेशन डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट कैन बी
यूटिलाइज टू एक्सटेंड द कैपेबिलिटीज ऑफ
वीबीए मैक्रोस बाय इनेबलिंग देम टू
इंटैक्ट विद Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
एग्जीक्यूट एक्सटर्नल कमांड्स मैनपुलेट
फाइल्स एंड फोल्डर्स एंड परफॉर्म अदर
सिस्टम रिलेटेड टास्क। इसका मतलब क्या है?
जो वीबीए क्या है? अगर हम बात करें विजुअल
बेसिक फॉर एप्लीकेशन के कॉन्टेक्स्ट में
वीबीए इंटरनली क्या होता है?
रिस्ट्रिक्टेड होता है। कहां तक? ऑफिस
एप्लीकेशन तक। जैसा कि हमने प्रीवियस
क्लास में देखा था कि मैंने आपको बताया था
कि जो वीबीए है एक बच्चा होता है जिसका
दायरा लिमिट होता है। किसके अंदर?
Microsoft Office के अंदर तक ही इससे बाहर
नहीं जाता। वह उसकी जो लिमिटेशन है उतनी
ही है और क्योंकि उसकी लिमिटेशन इतनी
क्यों है? क्योंकि उसका प्राइमरी काम क्या
है? Microsoft Word, एक्सेल या पावर पॉइंट
के अंदर तक ही लिमिट है। क्योंकि उससे
बाहर उसका काम ही नहीं है। इसलिए उसका
दायरा लिमिट किया गया है। जैसे डॉक्यूमेंट
में फॉर्मेटिंग करना है, टेबल्स बनाना है,
कैलकुलेशंस करना है, ग्राफ बनाना है, पाई
चार्ट बनाना है। यही तो काम है उसका काम
ऑटोमेशन परफॉर्म करने के लिए। इसलिए उसकी
लिमिटेशन सेट की गई है। और इसीलिए अगर हम
बात करें कि जो वर्ड और एक्सेल के केस में
कि वर्ड और एक्सेल या जो Microsoft Office
सूट है उसके बाहर Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
पर उसका जो डायरेक्ट कंट्रोल है किसका?
वीबीए का बहुत ही लिमिटेड है। मतलब बहुत
ही लिमिटेड कंट्रोल है। मतलब इसीलिए बोला
कि एक घर घर तक ही लिमिट है उसका। उसके
लिए लिमिटेशन बहुत है। लेकिन फिर भी अगर
जो वीबीए है फिर भी अगर जो आपका वीबीए है
उसको होस्ट Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के
साथ इंटैक्ट करना हो तो कैसे करेगा? मेरा
सवाल यह है कि फिर भी अगर वीबीए को होस्ट
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के साथ इंटैक्ट
करना तो कैसे करेगा? मतलब अगर किसी हैकर
या डेवलपर को वीबीए के जरिए माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
के वर्ड से बाहर निकलकर Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम पर कुछ काम करवाना है। जैसे
Windows रजिस्ट्री में कुछ चेंज करवाना
है, सिस्टम कमांड्स रन करवानी है, सीएमडी
पे कुछ काम करवाना है, पावर सेल में कुछ
काम करवाना है या कंप्यूटरटर्स में किसी
दूसरी जगह से फाइल को रीड करना है, राइट
करना है, डिलीट करना है या इंटरनेट से
एक्सटर्नल फाइल डाउनलोड करवानी है। अगर ये
सारे काम करवाने हैं वीबीए की हेल्प से तो
आप कैसे करवाओगे? एज ए हैकर Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम से कैसे इंटैक्ट करोगे?
ठीक है? क्योंकि जो वीबीए के पास ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम पर डायरेक्ट कंट्रोल नहीं होता। जो
उसकी इनबिल्ट पावर है वो बहुत ज्यादा
लिमिटेड होती है। इसलिए जो आपका वीबीए है
वो किसका यूज़ करता है? डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट
का यूज़ करता है। डब्ल्यूस्क्रिप्ट की मदद
लेता है। अंडरस्टुड एवरीवन?
समझ में आया? क्लास तो छोड़ के चले गए और
आप बोल रहे हो सर कंटिन्यू करो।
कि डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट क्या है? एक ऐसा
ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल है या एक ऐसा स्क्रिप्टिंग
एनवायरमेंट है जो क्या करता है कि जो आपकी
कमांड लाइन है या जो विंड ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
है उसके साथ क्या करता है? डायरेक्ट
इंटैक्ट करता है।
सीधा सिंपल मतलब आप क्लास लोग क्लास तो
छोड़कर चले गए यार। आप लोग चार पांच लोग
आते हो। उनमें से भी तीन लोग चले गए तो
फिर मैं क्या कंटिन्यू करूं? आपको तभी
मैंने ऑप्शन दिया था कि अगर टॉपिक स्टार्ट
कर दिया तो टॉपिक को फील लेके पढ़ना
पड़ेगा। फील लेके पढ़ाना भी पड़ेगा। अब
अगर आप क्लास लोग क्लास छोड़ के जा ही रहे
हो तो फायदा क्या हुआ टॉपिक का? फिर मैं
कल कंटिन्यू करूंगा नेक्स्ट क्लास में।
चलिए फिर हम कल करेंगे कंटिन्यू आप क्लास
को अगर छोड़ के जाए तो हम एक काम करेंगे
वीबीओ को फिर स्टार्टिंग से हम कवर करेंगे
इसको डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्टिंग को डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट क्या होता है तो आज इतना ही
करते हैं फिर ओके आप लोग क्लास को ऐसे मत
छोड़कर जाया करो कल कंटिन्यू करेंगे फिर
ओके इसको
नहीं वह देखते हैं मैं मानता हूं बट जो
डेली आते हैं यार उनका तो छोड़ सोचो ना
क्योंकि देखो ये स्किपिंग टॉपिक है काफी
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है इसमें एक-एक चीज
बिल्कुल ध्यान से हमें बोलना पड़ेगा ध्यान
से आपको समझना पड़ेगा बिल्कुल प्यार से एक
भी चीज मैं मैंने आपकी साइड अपनी साइड से
मिस की अगर आपने उसको सुनना मिस किया तो
मे बी आपको यह समझ में नहीं आए बिकॉज़
आपका जो पेलोड डेवलपमेंट है जो आप पेलोड
बनाना सीखोगे जो आप पेलोड बनाओगे जो
ड्रॉपर्स बनाओगे वो उस यह इसी के बेस पे
बनेगा यही वो जगह है जो आपको समझनी बहुत
ज्यादा जरूरी है।
ओके
चलिए मैं आपका क्वेश्चन ले लेता हूं। कल
लेंगे कोई कोई बात नहीं। हम डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट से और वीबी इंटीग्रेशन से
कंटिन्यू करते हैं। कोई दिक्कत नहीं है।
इसको कंटिन्यू कर लेंगे। नो इशू।
ओके? तो इसको आज इतना ही करते हैं। आपको
अगर कोई डाउट है तो मुझसे पूछ लेना। कल
इसको फिर से हम दोबारा मैं रिपीट कर
दूंगा। क्योंकि फोर टू फाइव स्लाइड है बट
अराउंड 20 मिनट्स लगेंगे इसमें।
एनोनिमस कितनी वीडियो आएंगी?
मेरे हिसाब हिसाब से इसमें 100 और वीडियो
आएंगी। मेरे हिसाब से 100
मेरे हिसाब से इसमें 100 और आएंगी।
जो मुझे लगता है इसमें 100 कम से कम
एटलीस्ट आएंगी।
तो सोचो कितना बड़ा है।
बहुत कुछ है भाई इसमें बहुत कुछ आप लोगों
के। आपके बहुत पैसे बचने वाले हैं। पर
धीरे-धीरे बीच में आपको जो चीज सिखानी
होंगी उसको हम एज ए वर्क
वर्कशॉप भी सिखा लेंगे पेड में।
क्या हो गया अनोनिमस लैब सॉल्व क्यों नहीं
हो पाती
फ्लैप सॉल्व भी हो जाएंगे डोंट वरी
क्योंकि देखो मैं सारी चीजें धीरे-धीरे
करवा रहा हूं हो जाएगी हो जाएगी हम अभी
इसके बाद
आपके लिए ऐसे इंटरेस्टिंग इंटरेस्टिंग
टॉपिक लेके आएंगे। डोंट वरी।
आपको लिए आपको एआई सीखना पड़ेगा। देखो मैं
आपको एक छोटा
बात बता देता हूं। देखो एक सच है। थोड़ा
सा कड़वा है। साइबर सिक्योरिटी में आप
जितना पढ़ सकते हो उतना पढ़ो। फंडामेंटल
सारे क्लियर करो और आप लोग आप आजकल
बोलेंगे कि सर हम वीबीए डेवलपमेंट अब मैं
आपको एक एग्जांपल देता हूं कि नेक्स्ट में
मैं आपको वीबीए की प्रोग्रामिंग क्लास
करवाऊंगा जैसे कि वीबीए को कैसे प्रोग्राम
करते हैं और कैसे-कैसे किया जाता है। अब
वो तो है तो हालांकि तो मैनुअल वर्क ही आप
बोलोगे सर कि अभी जमाना चला गया मैनुअल का
तो हम एआई से क्यों नहीं करवा लेते? भाई
आप राइट हो आप सही हो क्योंकि एआई का
जमाना है। एआई वो कोड जस्ट फ्रिक्शन ऑफ
सेकंड में आपके लिए लिख देगा। बट एक बात
बताइए एआई मशियस कोड तो नहीं लिखता।
एआई
मशियस कोड तो नहीं लिखेगा आपके लिए। पेलोड
नहीं लिखेगा एआई आपके लिए।
ठीक है ना? पेलोड नहीं लिखेगा। तो लेकिन
एक चीज है कि आपने बेसिक पता कर लिया कि
मोटा-मोटा कैसे लिखा जाता है। वेरिएबल
होते हैं, कंडीशंस होते हैं। यह चीज होती
है और वीबी ऐसे काम करती है। मैक ऐसे काम
करता है और ऐसेसे हम काम करवा सकते हैं।
अगर आपने ये चीज सीख ली तो एi तो ह्यूमन
बीइंग तो नहीं है ना। मशीन है उसको ट्रिक
करना है।
लिखवा सकते हो आप एआई से कोड उसको ट्रैक
करना है। क्योंकि एआई में क्या है? कुछ
कंटेंट पॉलिसी में कुछ कीवर्ड हैं। कुछ
चीजें हैं जो आप वो यूज़ करते हो तुरंत वो
डिटेक्ट करता है और आपको वो कोड नहीं लिख
के देता। तो आपको फिर उसको ट्रैक करना है।
तो वो ट्रैक कब कर पाओगे? जब आप कर पाओगे
कि आपने फॉर एग्जांपल Python बेसिक लेवल
पर सीख लिया। आपको पता है कि Python में
कैसे कोडिंग की जाती है। प्रोफेशनल लेवल
पे नहीं। आपको पता है फंक्शनंस कैसे बने,
वेरिएबल्स कैसे बनेंगे। मतलब अगर आप खुद
से कोड करने बैठो आप समझ पाओगे कि अगर
आपने कोड देखा क्योंकि ये Python का कोड
है और ऐसे-ऐसे काम कर रहा होगा। बस इतना
इनफ सीखा इतना एनफ। सारी चीज़ इतनी एनफ।
आपने इतनी सारी चीजें सीख ली तो तब आप एi
को अच्छे से यूज़ कर पाओगे। और मैं यह
बोलता हूं कि अगर आपको पूरा ऑटोमेशन सीखना
है तो आपको एआई को अडॉप करना पड़ेगा। सीखना
पड़ेगा।
एआई डेवलपमेंट, मशीन लर्निंग
ये सारी चीज करनी पड़ेगी। एआईएमएल आपको
पढ़ना पड़ेगा। और जब एआई एमएल आप पढ़ोगे
देन एक और चीज है कि बहुत सारे बेसिक डाउट
है लोगों के क्योंकि एआई की क्लास में भी
मैं अभी मैं इसको मैं प्रॉमिस नहीं कर
सकता। इतनी सारी चीजें नहीं कर सकता।
प्रॉमिस आप बोलो सर फिर मैं झूठा साबित हो
जाऊंगा। तो मैं एआई के रिलेटेड अभी
प्रॉमिस नहीं कर रहा। तो लेके आऊंगा तो
मैं सीधा लेकर ही आऊंगा। तो भाई एक बात
बताओ कि जब आप एआई को अगर ट्रेन भी करोगे
तो उसके लिए भी तो आपको पता होना चाहिए कि
आप किस वलनेबिलिटी पर ट्रेन कर रहे हो
वनबिलिटी कैसे काम करती है और उससे आप
क्या ट्रेन करवाना चाह रहे हो वो आप तभी
कर पाओगे जब आपको पता होगा कि वो कैसे काम
करती है कैसे वो पाई जाती है कैसे आपको
फाइंड आउट करनी है और आपको खुद नॉलेज होगी
तभी आप उसको कर पाओगे ना ऑटोमेटिव
अब सारी चीजें आप एआई पे छोड़ोगे तो फिर
आपको भी नहीं पता ना कि वो क्या कर रहा है
क्या नहीं कर रहा साइबर सिक्योरिटी
ऑटोमेशन परफॉर्म करना द बेस्ट अपॉर्चुनिटी
यह प्रोजेक्ट आपको करने भी चाहिए बट आपको
नॉलेज भी होने चाहिए। अगर फॉर एग्जांपल
मैंने आपको सोशल इंजीनियरिंग पढ़ाया और
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग में मैंने इतनी सारी
चीजें पढ़ाई हैं। अगर आप डायरेक्टली उसको
ब्लाइंडली एआई को देखो आपको कंटेंट पॉलिसी
के वायलेट करके आपको कुछ नहीं बताएगा। बट
आपको पता है कि चीजें कैसे काम करती है।
क्या-क्या करवाना है तो आपको सोचना
पड़ेगा। अगर आप सीधे हाथ से कान नहीं पकड़
सकते। आपको घुमाना पड़ेगा। कितना घुमा के
कान पकड़वाएगी एआई वो आपको सोचना है और वह
आप तभी कर पाओगे जब आपके पास वो नॉलेज
होगी। आपके पास वो ट्रिक्स होंगी और
ट्रिक्स आपको सिर्फ नॉलेज से आएगी।
आप लोगों को लगता है कि यूज़लेस होगा कि
हम क्यों पढ़ रहे हैं अभी भी बेस से?
क्यों अभी भी मैं एसक्यूएल पढ़ रहा हूं?
क्यों एक्सेस पढ़ रहा हूं? क्यों? व्हाई?
क्यों मैं यह अभी भी वीबीए मैक पढ़ रहा
हूं। जो 2016 के जो 2016 का जो ऑफिस है वह
इसको बैन कर रहा है। क्यों?
भैया क्योंकि पूरी तरह चीजें नहीं बदली
अभी भी।
कौन सी कार्तिक कौन सी क्लास कंप्लीट करनी
है? देखो मेरा सेशन रहता है। मैं एक चीज
मैंने अपने कई क्लासेस मैंने अराउंड 74
फोर्थ क्लास है मेरी। ये ठीक है? तो 73
क्लास तक मैंने एक चीज नोटिस की है। अगर
मैं सेशन एक घंटे से ऊपर अगर पढ़ाता हूं
खासकर थ्योरेटिकल सेशन तो मुझे पता है खुद
मैं 1 घंटे से ऊपर किसी थ्योरी सेशन को
अटेंड नहीं कर पाऊंगा तो तुम्हें कैसे
एक्सपेक्टेशन कर सकता हूं कि 1 घंटे से
ज्यादा पढ़ोगे। कोई नहीं अगर वो ब्रेकडाउन
हो रहा है सेशन को। पार्ट 1 2 3 4 5 10 तक
जाने दो। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है। बट आपका
कॉन्सेप्ट क्लियर होना चाहिए। आप जब क्लास
में आओ आप प्रेजेंट रहने चाहिए ना कि आप
45 या 50 मिनट के बाद क्लास में बोर होने
लगो या क्लास से छोड़ने की सोचो उससे बेटर
यह है ना कि कोई बात नहीं सर ने यहां पर
आज क्लास छोड़ी है कोई बात नहीं आप आप
सीखना चाहते हो आपके मन में तो जिज्ञासा
ना सीखने की कल करेंगे भाई कोई दिक्कत
नहीं और अभी मैं धीरे-धीरे फ्रीक्वेंसी
बढ़ाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं फ्रीक्वेंसी
बढ़ाने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं जैसे-जैसे
मुझे टाइम मिलेगा फ्रीक्वेंसी बढ़ाने की
कोशिश कर रहा हूं मैं डीए की
कोई भी प्रोजेक्ट ले लो यार अगर आप पहले
अनोनिमस आप किस फील्ड में भी हो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी में ही हो प्रोजेक्ट तो आप
डिपेंड करता है आप कोई भी ले सकते हो
ओके नहीं मुझे पता है यार आप सब लोग एक
जैसे नहीं होते कार्तिक भाई देखो हर टाइप
का स्टूडेंट आता है मुझे सबको इक्वली
देखना है
मेरे रेगुलर जो स्टूडेंट्स हैं उनको तो
मैं 100% इक्वली ही देखूंगा।
एमएसटी साइबर सिक्योरिटी में तो आप एआई का
यूज करके प्रोजेक्ट बनाए बेटर रहेगा और आई
ओटी यूज़ करोगे तो और भी बढ़िया है।
देखो ऑटोमोबाइल के मुझे भी सच बताऊं मैं
अभी खुद इतना एक्सपर्ट नहीं हूं ऑटोमोबाइल
सिक्योरिटी में। तो मैं खुद नहीं पढ़ा
सकता। मैं आपको नहीं घुमा रहा मैं कि मैं
करवा दूंगा। ऑटोमोबाइल
की मुझे इतनी ज्यादा एक्सपर्टीज नहीं है।
चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड करते हैं। ओके कल
करेंगे कंटिन्यू। तो कल डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट
से करेंगे क्या चीज होती है। उसके बाद कोई
बात नहीं परसों कर लेंगे प्रैक्टिकल।
प्रैक्टिकल तो एंटर कर रहे हैं हम। इसके
बाद जैसे कि पार्ट थ्री होगा। कल पार्ट
थ्री होगा मोस्ट प्रोबेब्ली क्योंकि वही
होगा। उसके बाद हम प्रैक्टिकल में एंटर
करेंगे। माइक्रो डेवलप प्रैक्टिकल की बहुत
सारी क्लासेस हैं। कई क्लासेस मैं लूंगा।
बिलकुल स्टार्टिंग की एक-एक चीज़ बताऊंगा
कि वेरिएबल क्या होता है? इफ कंडीशन
कैसी-कैसी होती है। बस मैं आपके सामने
परफॉर्म भी करके दिखाऊंगा और आपको समझाऊं
मीगा। उसके बाद हमें अपने पर्पस से उसको
यूज़ करना है। तो हम अपने पर्पस से कैसे
यूज़ करेंगे वो मैं आपको बताऊंगा। डोंट
वरी। तो अभी प्रैक्टिकल पे हम
प्रैक्टिकल्स पे हम एंटर कर रहे हैं। इसकी
चिंता मत कीजिए। तो कल की क्लास मिस मत
करना। तो कल भी आना क्योंकि यह जो डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट है ना अभी इससे पहले आपने
फंडामेंटल जो पढ़ लिया पढ़ लिया डब्ल्यू
स्क्रिप्ट आपका मेन टॉपिक है जो भी काम
करता है आपका यह डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट ही
करता है
एआई आपको स्पेसिफिक साइबर साइबर के साथ
आपको एआई इंक्लूड करना करना पड़ेगा। तो
देन ओनली यू कैन डू ऑल ऑफ द थिंग्स
ऑटोमेटिक।
अंडरस्टुड गाइस? चलिए फिर सेशन को एंड
करते हैं और कल मिलते हैं शाम को सेम
टाइम। सेम आप लोग आने की कोशिश करना
क्योंकि अच्छा रहता है। लाइव इंटरेक्शन हो
जाता है आप लोगों के लिए। तो चलिए फिर
सेशन को रखते हैं। बाय-ब एंड गुड नाइट
एवरीवन। टेक केयर एंड सी यू फॉर टुमारो
गाइस।